madame monsieur bonsoir une question
pour commencer ce journal qui a fomenté
mercredi soir à bourganeuf
les deux attentats contre des
travailleurs immigrés turcs
la question reste sans réponse
aujourd'hui à bourganeuf les victimes
met en cause deux personnes un gendarme
et un commerçant qui avait été gardé à
vue jeudi puis relâché le jour même par
la gendarmerie de bourganeuf affaire
trouble confuse la population de
bourganeuf craint que ces attentats
nuisent à la bonne entente qui régnait
alors entre les communautés françaises
et turques
un reportage de la mecque les pensées
qui sont là je travaillais comme le
racisme
un mal inconnu jusqu'à ces derniers
temps des 4000 habitants de bourganeuf
jamais le moindre incident jamais la
moindre insulte entre les français et la
communauté immigrée 300 personnes dont
53 turc premiers symptômes
une alerte à la bombe le mois dernier
dans un café fréquenté par des immigrés
et puis mercredi soir dans un logement
de travailleurs turcs 7 rue du biez
adour une décharge violente de
chevrotine dont la porte garde encore
les traces la chevrotine une cartouche
de très grandes puissances dont
l'utilisation est interdite en france
depuis quatre ans en tirant à hauteur
d'homme l'agresseur avait sans doute
l'intention de tuer heureusement à cet
instant l'appartement était vide
quelques instants après la fenêtre d'une
autre maison où se trouvaient une
dizaine d'immigrés était brisée par une
grenade lacrymogène suivie immédiatement
de coups de feu
il faut que les coûts de leur défensive
le sens sortie on n'a vu personne mais
nous avoir écoutés des bruits de pas
ainsi que des voix et ce ne sont là que
nous avons pris la direction doublé les
voiliers plus de 20 hélas arrivé au
carrefour
nous avons vu ainsi que de la com en
fermant je connais pas et dès qu'il met
en vue ils ont jeté le fusil dans la
fosse et les processions dans cette
arrivée il aurait montré le rôle de
fidélité les gendarmes sont descendus et
là effectivement candidat est la même il
a reconnu que cet avis en disant aux
gendarmes que c'est fait c'est à moi et
que j'ai le droit de le trimbaler
désarmant fête en voiture
il a parcouru vous devoir durer plus il
a reconnu les avoir tiré dessus avec le
livre vert qu'on les avons tenus quand
les ans qu'on nous les avons cerné il a
reconnu avoir tiré par dessus me l'a dit
parce que je me suis trouvé en face
d'eux n'avait pas tiré dessus ce qu'il
est une affaire grave puisque un
gendarme et un commerçant sont mises en
cause par les victimes
une affaire qui indignent la
municipalité et une grande partie de la
population en non je crois que ça
dépasse le fait divers isolé à
bourganeuf ya des faits divers mais le
fait que ce soit deux attentats qu'ils
soient dirigés contre deux locaux qui
étaient habités par des turcs et où où
tout le monde savait que les turcs
habitée a une signification
incontestablement raciale et nous sommes
inquiets de ce que tu étais là et de se
réclame le suivant de très près la faire
nous avons d'ailleurs alerté le très
vite les pouvoirs publics nous les
avions déjà alerté avant même les
incidents qui se sont produits il y a
un jour peut-être pas assez de travail
pour tout le monde un tel cas pas assez
de travail bon c'est possible moi je
suis chômeur un chômeur depuis quelques
temps maintenant et j'ai pas fais
attentats contre les turcs parce qu'ils
ont comme on dirait manger moins 5 à ces
cas-là faire leur boulot
d'ores et déjà les agresseurs quels
qu'ils soient ont atteint leur but
il y a un problème racial à bourganeuf
des rumeurs circulent certains habitants
gêné par le pudiquement de problème
d'autres préfèrent se taire
quant aux victimes elles font confiance
la justice française pour éclaircir la
faire